bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de ski mag réinventer les quartiers pour
répondre aux nouveaux besoins ou
nouveaux usages accompagner l'économie
et favoriser les nouvelles mutations
respecter les impératifs liés au
changement climatique
autant de défis que souhaite relever
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de grands
chantiers sont actuellement à l'oeuvre
sur le territoire je vous propose d'en
faire le tour c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est plutôt bien d'embellir le quartier
de rénover d'améliorer l'accessibilité
etc et tous les services associés donc
excellente initiative en tant
qu'habitante de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de
montigny-le-bretonneux donc je participe
justement aux ateliers pour les travaux
de l'hyper centre et ça c'est génial ça
va dans le sens de l'histoire de
l'avenir
les énergies vertes c'est tout à fait
positif
les sévères et au est complètement dans
le ton actuellement par rapport au béton
que nous avons depuis 40 ans c'est bien
de rendre les choses un peu plus piéton
un peu plus plus de verdure je pense que
c'est une très bonne chose ça va
redynamiser la ville je pense que sont
la ville de saint-quentin ya déjà eu
beaucoup d'efforts fournis à ce niveau
là si la ville qui nous va bien
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines est un
territoire qui a su mêler de manière
équilibrée et harmonieuse habitat
services entreprise espaces verts de
manière très importante et l'endroit où
nous nous trouvons dans l'hyper centre
de montigny en est l'illustration avec
la gare un parc situé juste en face des
immeubles de bureaux et des logements
tout le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines aujourd'hui est en réflexion
pour continuer d'évoluer
ex villes nouvelles le paysage de saint
quentin en yvelines n'a eu de cesse
d'évoluer au cours des 50 dernières
années une évolution plus que jamais
d'actualité
il ya d'abord le besoin des habitants du
territoire et ça c'est une préoccupation
est évidemment très très forte pour les
élus que nous sommes il ya ensuite à
savoir répondre aux nouveaux besoins des
entreprises la crise de l'aco vide en
plus à renforcer l'évolution que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui est donc on doit
pouvoir s'adapter à cela et puis après
il ya aussi des exigences qui se posent
en matière de transition écologique et
qui font qu'on ne peut plus penser à un
territoire de la même façon aujourd'hui
à montigny le bretonneux s'annonce un
chantier colossal conçu dans les années
80 le quartier hypercentre concentre le
principal pôle économique de saint
quentin en yvelines des commerces et le
centre commercial régional
la gare
l'université et le théâtre très minéral
ce lieu a récemment été repensé en
concertation avec les habitants place
aux piétons et à la verdure la place
georges pompidou sera traversé en son
centre par des bassins est bordée
d'arbres plus d'eau davantage de
végétaux mais aussi d'animations pour
plus de convivialité
alors nous avons la venue du centre qui
est juste derrière nous la place
pompidou tout le circuit du canal qui
traverse le centre commercial et puis
aussi la place de la gare avec la
l'immeuble de l'anneau rouge qui est
juste derrière nous et qui va être
prochainement démolie pour que l'on voir
se reconstruire à la place des immeubles
de bureaux mais qui seront ouvert sur le
quartier de façon à ce que la place de
la gare deviennent visibles désormais
sur l'avenue du centre nous souhaitons
réduire la place de la voiture est
proposé à la place des espaces
piétonniers des terrasses étendu pour
les cafés et les restaurants des pistes
cyclables également parce que c'est un
enjeu fort je crois pour nous
aujourd'hui de permettre aux gens
d'accéder facilement la gare et d'en
partir facilement à vélo
à l'autre extrémité de l'avenue du
centre rénovation complète de l'ensemble
immobilier de la noue rouge en serrant
la gare celle ci devrait connaître elle
aussi une mutation importante
en 2030 la future gare saint quentin est
accueillera la ligne 18 du grand paris
express
il est essentiel parce que il va
apporter un nouveau circuit déplacement
et ajoutez donc des capacités de
transport sur le territoire de saint
quentin et nous savons que c'est la clé
dans l'avenir avec tout le problème que
nous avons aujourd'hui sur les
déplacements des habitants en région
ile-de-france d'avoir cette nouvelle
ligne qui va venir apporter là aussi des
solutions de mobilité c'est essentiel ça
va nous permettre aussi de développer un
nouveau quartier le quartier des savoirs
sur la vie de guyancourt et évidemment
tout le travail que nous faisons
aujourd'hui de regarder comment cette
station qui arrivera dans le cas de la
ligne 18 sera en connexion avec le la
gare de montigny saint quentin par
exemple mais toutes les tous les pôles
de mobilité que l'on peut avoir sur le
territoire puisque là aussi l'objectif
évidemment c'est de favoriser les
déplacements par ce type de transport à
l'avenir
des projets d'envergure seront amorcés
cette année dans bon nombre de communes
de l'agglomération
à la verrière avec la restructuration du
pôle gare la création du futur site
olympique sur la colline d'elancourt la
réhabilitation du carrefour de la malle
me donne à l'intersection de maurepas
coignières et la verrière
[Musique]
autres rénovations l'immobilier
d'entreprise d'importantes
transformations ont déjà eu lieu elles
vont se poursuivre impulsée par les
nouvelles méthodes de travail de
nouveaux usages accélérée par la crise
sanitaire
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines pour être
attractif à une vraie politique sur son
parc d'immobilier d'entreprise puisque
quand une entreprise cherche à
s'implanter sur un territoire bon elle
va bien sûr être attentives au cadre de
vie elle va être attentives la mobilité
aux différentes possibilités d'accès
mais également à l'immobilier
d'entreprise à dire quel type de locaux
on peut leur offrir
nous avons un parc très très important
surtout saint quentin en yvelines et
nous travaillons beaucoup à la
restructuration à la réhabilitation ou à
la reconstruction également du mobilier
existant
on peut par exemple comme exemple
l'immeuble international qui est un
immeuble de bureaux en pied de gars qui
alors les tissus des l'urbanisation et
du développement de saint quentin dans
les années 80 donc c'est assez ancien et
aujourd'hui c'est un immeuble de bureaux
de vingt mille mètres carrés qui
s'appelle le carré et qui accueille
aujourd'hui l'ingénieriste explo et qui
ado c'est en plus un immeuble de
logements ce qui est assez assez
novateur
d'autres sites ont également opéré leur
transformation
l'immeuble le native lui actuellement en
construction accueillera bientôt le
groupe orange à proximité la noue rouge
restructurer sera composé de trois
immeubles tertiaires et saint-quentin du
coup accompagne toutes ses opérations
avec des restructuration urbaine telle
que le complet réaménagement de la place
charles de gaulle voilà donc le l'espace
public vient également à l'appui 20 de
ces qualifications
ce quartier qui était emblématique et
qui date des années 80
reprend une nouvelle nouvelle jeunesse
et surtout ce qui est important dans la
stratégie de saint-quentin masse et de
s'adapter aux nouveaux modes de travail
donc là l'importance du numérique
l'importance du lait télétravail mais
aussi on voit maintenant de plus en plus
d'entreprises qui ont besoin de moins d
espace où des espaces différents pour
travailler autrement on est en train de
justement de travailler à pouvoir
proposer une offre de coworking et puis
aussi de ce qu'on appelle deux tiers
lieux on a beaucoup de gens qui
commencent à se lancer dans le le tiers
lieux qui sont des lieux partagé où on
peut travailler ensemble faire des
ateliers des formations faire des
animations parce que l'entreprise c'est
pas que travailler ça peut être aussi un
endroit où on peut aborder gêné faire du
sport donc tout ça doit être aussi pris
en compte dans l'évolution de nos de
notre immobilier d'entreprise et de nos
zones d'activités en particulier
autre lieu autre projet à voisins le
bretonneux dans le futur écoquartier de
la remise au programme plus de 500
logements des commerces des jardins
potagers un pool crise pour les plus
sportifs et une crèche on visite
dans le processus même de la
consultation qui a été fait dans le
montage du projet on a fait quelque
chose de totalement novateur dans la
façon de monter à 2 proposait à des
groupements de travailler pour pouvoir
proposer des solutions multiples avec
des choses très innovante sur la façon
d'aménager un quartier
derrière le centre aquatique du lac le
futur éco quartier sera implanté sur 10
hectares à l'horizon 2024
six promoteurs ont proposé un projet
alliant innovation et hautes
performances environnementales
quand vous regardez cet éco quartier va
vous remarquer qu'on a conservé
évidemment tous les tous les arbres à
hautes tiges que déjà les allées les
allées sont tracées et qu'en fait c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle nous avons
gagné ce concours c'est que autour de
ces arbres on vient en fait enfiler des
bâtiments qui vont avoir bien sûr des
vues sur cette nature
le projet comprend 530 logements 1700 m²
de commerces et services une crèche un
relais d'assistantes maternelles un pôle
glisse des salles associatives
55% des espaces végétalisés dont 11000
mètres carrés des jardins potagers et
une église
cet écho à retirer répond bien à 3 à 3
maîtrise vous avez la maîtrise de
l'habiter vous avez la maîtrise de
l'habitat et vous avez la maîtrise de
l'habitant la maîtrise de la et ses
bains venir au sein d'un quartier
existant dans trois ans quand tout sera
terminé il faut qu'on ait l'impression
que cette construction ce quartier était
bien pensé et vient s'intégrer dans la
totalité de l'environnement donc il
s'intègre à côté de collèges d'école on
n'a pas déjà parler bien sûr des
terrains de sport il ya même une station
essence et pourquoi pas ça fait partie
de la vie aussi les commerces qui seront
là il habita c'est les innovations par
la construction bois et c'est aussi
surtout la qualité architecturale
l'habitant lui n'aura plus qu'à
s'approprier les lieux pour se faire une
association investir à l'éco quartier
durant trois ans
l'association est là pour apprendre aux
gens comment cette biodiversité et ce
développement des jardins partagés et de
tout le paysage et de la façon dont ils
vont vivre dans ce parc ils sont là pour
aider les gens à avoir on va dire les
bons réflexes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]